the Mediterranean holiday island of
Majorca attracts plenty of British
tourists every year and about 17,000 UK
citizens have already settled in the
popular resort of mock aloof on the west
coast well I'm worried obviously I've
lived here a long time my husband's
Spanish and well yesterday I was
European and now I'm an immigrant I
don't know exactly what I am because I'm
British I have a British passport and
and now I live in Spain I've lived in
Spain over 30 years Julie is concerned
about her job as well selling tours and
tickets to British tourists could be
much harder after the sharp drop in the
value of the pound brexit hit the island
in the middle of a tourism boom tour
operators reported record bookings to
Spain recently terror attacks in Turkey
led many to choose Spain instead now
many local business people fear there
could be far fewer British visitors
arriving at all if they don't have
enough money at the end of the month
they'll obviously not have enough for
the holidays this economic crisis has
hit us all Brits don't have Sun or
beaches at home so they come here but if
the economy begins to struggle they'll
be less inclined to come here partner 30
that British tourists in my Orca could
not really imagine their compatriots
suddenly staying away from the island
but they're worried about the situation
back home am I worried about my job I
yes I am
I don't feel entirely comfortable I
think it's gonna be really volatile for
the next few months and probably beyond
that I have two kids and I I'm not sure
this is the right call for them I
obviously voted in I would have liked to
remain I think that gives us stability
I love Europe I feel European my Orca is
heavily dependent on British money that
Brits buy holiday homes and British
immigrants spend their pensions here
there pounds have suddenly declined in
value Britain also imports oil and wine
from the Balearic Islands my Orca would
have voted against brexit